blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman hi i'm farin cousins in for david
pakman and this is the david pakman show
obviously biggest news in the world
right now we've got to just jump right
into this and that is the deteriorating
situation in afghanistan
over the weekend the afghani president
was forced to evacuate the country
leaving the capital in kabul
to fall to the
taliban the taliban have been
encroaching throughout the country over
the last week or so in really
spectacular fashion uh you know just
taking over as much as they can and now
it appears
with them having seized the capital
we're in for quite the situation right
and if you've been following social
media over the weekend i'm sure you've
seen plenty of people
with opinions about what should and
should not happen in the country right
now
you've got the corporate controlled
media and of course all the republicans
out there telling us we've got to double
down biden himself sending 5 000 more
troops over the last week back to
afghanistan when we're supposed to be
getting all of our people out of
afghanistan u.s embassy has had to be
evacuated as well and then of course you
have the other side you have the people
who say listen
you can't send anybody over there
this is a 20-year trillion dollar
endless war
get the hell out and stay out
unfortunately
it's not as easy as all of these
armchair military strategists would have
you believe it's not as simple as the
united states sending thousands of
troops over there we'll get the taliban
out of the country again and oh
everything will be great not that simple
it's not as simple as walking around
saying oh well
we created this mess good luck dealing
with it that destabilizes you know the
region
so what is the answer
i don't know
i don't know and i i'm firmly willing to
admit
that i don't know and i think that's a
problem that a lot of folks have in this
business whether it's right or left
always desperate
to have a definitive answer as to what
we need to do and they're always so sure
of that answer but folks like i said
i think this is a situation that's not
as black and white as a lot of people
want to make it seem
i personally do not want any u.s troops
going back to afghanistan
but at the same time we have to also
look at what we did to that country we
did this
over 20 years
we helped to destabilize not just
afghanistan but the entire
region
with our ridiculous
and false foreign policy based on lies
then obama kept us there
trump acted like he was going to get us
out you know tried to negotiate with the
taliban but that didn't do much good and
so biden
comes along and says well we're going to
finish getting out of there
we didn't now we're going back
so what is the solution
you know can we just sit here and say
okay taliban afghanistan is yours we
screwed it up maybe you can do better um
i obviously don't think we can do that
is the answer sending thousands more
troops back to the country to just put
it back in the situation it was in
before we even left that's also a
terrible idea
unfortunately
there's no easy answers
and any answer we have has to address
the fact that the united states has made
this situation so much worse
the taliban now has their hands on all
these u.s weapons
that we've been sending over there for
decades now
they've got the strongholds they have
forced us out they have forced the
afghan government
out
and they say they're now waiting for a
peaceful transfer of power
so
again i i don't have a definitive answer
one suggestion i have at this point
is we need to do what george w bush
originally talked about doing until he
pissed off all our allies
is we we need a coalition
the united states has proven that we
can't handle the situation there we
never went in with an actual strategy
so it's kind of hard 20 years after the
fact to really be able to get a good
solid strategy a really good ground game
going because we never had one to begin
with so everybody else that comes along
all the other leaders obama trump and
biden they're having to piece it
together as they go
and nobody got it right
i mean what's happening right now in
afghanistan is proof that nobody got it
right the only difference is that for
all of those years the uh taliban
really only had control
on the outskirts you know the really
rural areas
of afghanistan that's that's where they
were able to
you know see progress that's when we
were able to fight them back
and as soon as we leave they come back
so the answer is not obviously sending
more troops over there for another 20
years so we have another generation of
american soldiers growing up
as part of this war machine that that
that's not that's not tenable that's not
something we can do
i do think the the best path forward at
this point
and again i'm not a military strategist
don't claim to be
but if we do not have a solid coalition
of allies
if we cannot get other countries
involved
to pledge
to protect this area
you know if we have to negotiate with
the taliban then we have to negotiate at
this point
but honestly i i don't know what else
and it all stems from those failures of
the war on terror
we have had republicans try this we have
had democrats try this this is now
bipartisan
failure with regards to our our
afghanistan foreign policy
so the solution is not going to come
from the united states
we need people that are better at this
we need people who can look at it a
little more objectively than the united
states can because we're still stuck in
that war on terror mentality that
followed the attacks of 9 11.
we're still not thinking clearly at this
point and again what's happening right
now is further proof of that
so if we can't get some cooler heads in
there if we can't get some real true
allies
you know maybe other nations in the
region
that can help us out
then this is what it is
and we're stuck with this mess that we
created
and in the meantime until we figure this
out the united states need to say listen
we're going to take afghan refugees
over the weekend
tens of thousands of people daily
trying to get out of the country because
they see what's happening they
understand
this is for real
okay this isn't a temporary insurgency
here that we're seeing this is
what their life may become now
and i would say after 20 years of
occupying their country
after helping to destabilize it
i'd say that's the least we could do is
take these people into our country and
that is the next step that i want to see
this biden administration take
acknowledge the failures of the united
states acknowledge that we don't have
the answers yet
and that is a terrifying thing for a
country to admit and i guarantee you
you'll never hear them say that
but at least we can do that
me everybody watching this
all of the other people left and right
out there with the armchair punditry
admit that we don't know
how to correctly handle this situation
because it sucks to have to admit that
you don't know it
but i think at this point that's where
we're at
and i don't think anybody can
definitively say that yes we i know for
certain we have to do this or we can't
do that
it's not that simple
but we're going to continue to watch
as the corporate media cnn's already out
there the major newspapers already out
there oh my god this is horrible we got
to get troops back there they're going
to push for war because war means
ratings war means advertisements
and that's what makes them money
on the other side of all of this
you have the republicans out there
non-stop over the weekend telling us
that this is a failure
of the biden administration this failure
rests solely on his shoulders
and whether it's fair or not
it does
he is the leader of the country right
now
this was a decision that was made
and so if
it succeeds or fails that is on him
and you may think it's fair you may
think it's not fair but it doesn't
matter politically speaking yes it is on
him
and republicans are going to do
everything they can to use that to their
advantage especially heading into the
midterms
look as we all know republicans have
struggled terrifically
trying to come up with any kind of
talking point to take down joe biden
you know going as far a couple months
ago to blame him for the chick-fil-a
sauce shortage
this is one that might stick
and that's even more terrifying folks
because if the midterm elections and
especially if the 2024 presidential
elections
become about failed foreign policy
and people get mad at the democrat who
inherited all of it and again i think
it's rather unfair for that to happen
but i understand that that is what is
going to happen then we're going to end
up with something terrible
that's a situation where you end up with
somebody like tom cotton coming out and
saying oh my god we've got to get back
over there look at all this instability
the democrats created the terrorists
have taken over i've been there
i know what it's like over there and i
know what we can do and people will
flock to that i promise you
i can promise you that because we've
seen it happen we saw it happen in the
2004 election
turmoil in the middle east
and the republicans unfortunately did a
much better job of messaging saying
we're the only ones that can keep you
safe
they did it through misinformation they
did it through lies they did it through
fake news and all of that yes but it
worked on the american public
so 2024 could end up being a repeat of
the 2004 election
based on that simple fact
and again that's the situation where you
end up with somebody worse you end up
with the worst kind of warhawk
at the top of that republican ticket
who is going to do unimaginable things
over there in the middle east where all
of this is taking place because it's not
just going to be about afghanistan
either
they're going to throw in iran
they're going to throw in syria they're
going to say look at all these
democratic failures
abroad that's bad news
that is bad
news for the democratic party
and it's bad news for the united states
as well and it's bad news for everybody
over there in the middle east because
again we end up with somebody worse and
i i picked tom cotton
because he is
somebody that served this could be the
kind of event that a guy like him needs
to really bolster up his poll numbers
because trust me he's not doing well so
far in all the little straw polls for
2024 so this could be the moment that
tom cotton emerges
as their guy as the republicans guy
you know ron desantis doesn't have that
ted cruz certainly doesn't have that
donald trump obviously doesn't have that
although he is going to try to use this
to his advantage as well
but the point is we can't go back to a
situation whether it is with a democrat
or a republican
where we think that we can bomb our way
out of the problem that's never going to
work
we tried it for 20
years
and an abrupt pull pullout here saying
well best of luck to you all while it's
best for us troops sure
we've destabilized the region created
hundreds of thousands of
you know
evacu refugees at this point not just
evacuees but refugees
with nowhere to go
and we have to own that as a country
as an administration they have to own
that
they may not have started this mess
but they've been with it every step of
the way unfortunately
so we have to do better we have to do
better for these people we have to do
better for the world and we have to get
more people on our side willing to take
a leadership role take it away from us i
feel
and we can offer the the support that
they need
i do not want another conflict in the
middle east i do not want more war i do
not want more dead soldiers whether it's
u.s soldiers or whether it's a foreign
country soldiers we don't need that at
all
so we have to put our best and brightest
together we got to get the intelligence
and i don't mean like covert and i mean
like literal intelligence
the smart people in the room need to
take things over and they need to get
with the other smartest people around
the country and try to figure out a way
that this doesn't end with more bombs
and more bloodshed but unfortunately i
do not think
that the cooler heads are going to
prevail in this situation and that is
not going to end well for anybody
i'm fair and cousins and for david
pakman we'll be right back
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist dot com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today you can
follow me on twitter at fair and balance
find me on facebook facebook.com slash
fair and balanced youtube youtube.com
slash the ring of fire and my other
youtube channel youtube.com slash fair
and balanced
let's get back into more of uh some of
the news here and i think one of the
biggest non-stories
of the last week
was mike lindell's cyber symposium that
as we all know came to a close at the
end of last week
august 13th came and went and in case
you haven't noticed donald trump is
still
not the president of the united states
nor
did we see president biden and vice
president harris resign
as lindell had also predicted at one
point
now
to his credit sure he had pushed back
the date of donald trump's reinstatement
he said well it's not going to happen
august 13th maybe september now he says
maybe later down the road but now it's
really looking
like it's not going to happen as if it
was ever going to happen
here's the thing
the cyber symposium was an absolute crap
show
and that is about putting it as nicely
as humanly possible
the guy got up there on stage kicked the
whole thing off with steve bannon who by
the way later in the week
came out and actually criticized lindell
for not providing any evidence at all
like the packet captures where the hell
were the packet
because they were nowhere to be seen
and of course the rest of the symposium
was nothing more than just powerpoints
that people had put together
with numbers that they didn't source
from anywhere they just said well here's
what it was but here's what we think it
really was
and they provided no evidence at all
to back up their little phony numbers
that they threw up on the screens
so you know there was that then of
course we had mike lindell's own cyber
security expert gave an interview to the
washington times where he said yeah
there was no evidence of any hack at all
so we could not sign off on lindell's
claims that there was a hack
lindell insisted there was anyway and in
fact actually when the gateway pundit
reported on the washington times
interview with that uh cyber security
expert lindell got up on stage
and he said well obviously the gateway
pundit person
is a cia plant
then of course you had his claim that he
was assaulted in his hotel room
or not his hotel room in his hotel lobby
and uh no record of this he showed up
the next day not a scratch on him
you know no police report filed so as
far as we know there was no actual
assault that took place and then on
friday at the end of all of this lindell
comes out gives an interview
basically tried to explain away why the
whole thing was an abject failure by
saying
it's because antifa infiltrated the
cyber symposium
that was that was his excuse antifa
infiltrated the cyber symposium they
went in there he said they changed the
name tags
and and then they
disrupt it that also didn't happen by
the way i feel the need to point that
out that didn't happen but but here's
the thing he didn't say what they did
after they changed the name tags
so like did they change the name tags
and just go sit in the crowd and watch
because if so i i don't think that's
throwing the whole thing off i think
that's just
whatever
the point is there was never any
evidence and that's why that cyber
symposium was a completely fact free
event
the only part of it that was even mildly
entertaining was when he found out his
lawsuit defamation lawsuit against him
was going to move forward and he bolted
off stage came back did a seven minute
rant against dominion voting systems
and again in an interview after the
thing ended he said oh well we're gonna
we're gonna have it all oh and he had
alan dershowitz
joined via zoom i believe and dershowitz
said oh yeah in the in the lawsuit the
discovery all this will come out bring
it
dominion is clearly not afraid
dominion as far as we know has
absolutely nothing to hide but what we
do know
is that all the ridiculous claims that
mike lindell made on stage will be used
against him in a court of law
because he won't stop the defamation
so yeah he's in trouble
he's in a lot of trouble with his
followers because he didn't give them
any information again even bannon the
guy who has platformed mike lindell for
months and months to spread these lies
called him out for not producing any
evidence
the packet captures that lindell been
talking about for months were nowhere to
be seen
and he also really destroyed any legal
defense he may have of course in that
defamation case
so rather than ending with a bang
rather than ending with the
reinstatement of former president donald
trump mike lindell's cyber symposium
ended with a whimper
a whimper that is really going to make
it hard for him to defend himself in
this dominion defamation lawsuit
moving on to other things how about
covid right covet
horrible all across the country
but as usual i'm going to start right
down here in my home state of florida
where as we know
our trump-loving republican governor ron
desantis
has said and they doubled down again on
this on friday
that any school district
that implements a mass mandate which is
a growing number of them at this point
we may cut off your funding
now according to reports on friday and
this really angered me because these
reports are totally inaccurate they said
that desantis had backed off
his claim to cut the salaries of
administrators
who
go along with these mass mandates
instead
what actually happened was you had a
desantis spokesperson christina pusha
who came out and said we're going to
leave it to the to the school boards
to voluntarily give up their salaries
for doing this once we cut their funding
so they didn't exactly back off it they
just realized oh wait we actually don't
have the authority to do it so we're
going to explain how it can be done but
we're still going to cut off your
funding they said
so over the weekend the biden
administration came out did the right
thing and said hold up now
any school district in the state of
florida oh and before i even get into
that biden actually called
some of the districts and thanked them
for putting mask mandates in place so
that was a good job as well biden is not
backing down off this
he is making sure that these people know
he has their back and so after the phone
calls
his administration came out and said
anywhere in the state of florida
if they cut off your funding for having
a masked mandate
we got your back and we'll make sure you
get the funding
if we have to we will use some of these
covet emergency funds
to fund your school district to pay your
salaries to do whatever we need to do
because we're not going to let this
florida tyrant
tell you
to make these horrible decisions that
could put your kids in danger
across the state in county after county
including counties that defied desantis
and did put mass mandates in place
we are seeing record numbers
of teachers administrators and students
out with covid or
having to quarantine because of exposure
broward county i think the number was
what 440
out
you also had four teachers in broward
county all die last week within hours of
each other
from covid
reopening these schools with no mask
mandates at all no vaccine mandates for
teachers or administrators
was one of the biggest mistakes we have
seen this
this state do
you know last year
they started doing away
with the virtual learning with the
distance learning
forcing most people to go brick and
mortar this year distance learning was
not even an option
it was brick and mortar or you become a
full-time homeschooler
and that's why we're seeing so many
problems we didn't even we didn't have
the option
we weren't given a choice
the only choice we have is whether or
not we personally send our kids to
school wearing a mask which yes i have
done
when i drop them off they have their
masks on when i pick them up they still
have their masks on i have no idea what
happens all throughout the day though
with those masks
are they taking it off as soon as i drop
them off are they putting it on when
they see me walking up i don't know
and i don't know what any of the other
children are doing there either except i
do know when i go to pick them up in the
afternoon there's only a handful of kids
wearing masks and i've only seen one
staff member wearing a mask when i've
gone to pick up my children one
this situation is about to become so
much worse
we're now a full week down
hundreds of people throughout the state
as a result of exposure at school either
on quarantine
or
out with covid
and it's going to get worse as time goes
on
because we're not protecting our kids
desantis said he left the decision up to
the parents well the parents aren't
making the right decision here
and they're letting their kids get
exposed who then expose other children
all we have to do is have our kids wear
masks they had to do it all throughout
the school year last year
do you know how many problems it caused
none
there were no reports of any child being
injured from having to wear a mask
there was not mass hospitalizations
because children's oxygen levels dropped
due to wearing a mask
and that actually brings us to another
story here
in the united states
not just florida anymore we're talking
about the entire country the number of
children being hospitalized for covid
has hit a new record
and what's really disturbing too is that
even though we have a record number of
children
hospitalized recovered they still only
make up 2.4 percent
of coveted hospitalizations
so more kids than ever but because we
also have more people than
ever
this is what we have um
stories out on sunday telling us that
over in
texas i believe it was
they're doing what new york had to do in
the early days of the pandemic and
they're setting up hospital beds
in the parking garage it was either
texas or mississippi i forget oh but
mississippi actually did have an 8th
grader
die of covid
an 8th grader 13 14 years old
eligible for the vaccine but had not
received it as far as we know
died from covid
because there was no safe way
to send all these kids back to school
and for the record yes
under 18 hospitalizations are at a
record high you know what else is going
up
the 19 through 29 the 30 through 39 the
40 through 49 in every age group the
number of coveted hospitalizations is
approaching an all-time high
and unfortunately this delta variant
does seem to be far more disastrous for
younger people even for healthy people
without any co-morbidities than original
covid
the disease is getting worse the virus
is getting worse it's continuing to
mutate and it's affecting people that a
year ago if they got covered well wasn't
a big deal
or they may have even been asymptomatic
from it
that's no longer the case remember i
mean remember that last summer they said
well you know this is a disease of the
elderly or the obese or people with a
lot of comorbidities
not anymore
we are seeing formerly healthy people
die of this
we are seeing people come out of this
that may have permanent lung problems
as a result of this disease
and republican leaders continue to
whistle past the graveyard
digging in their heels and saying nope
we're not going to change what we've
already done
because oh well then it might make us
look foolish
protect your citizens
i promise you you're going to get
rewarded politically more
for helping your residents than you will
for letting them
die
i don't know why it's so hard for these
republican leaders to get that through
their brains
but that's the situation we're dealing
with now
you can either piss off the minority of
people who are anti-mask and anti-vaxx
or
you can kill off enough of your base to
where you'll never win an election again
seems like a pretty simple equation to
me
i'm faring cousins after david pakman
we'll be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins sitting in for david
today don't forget you can find me on
twitter at twitter.com
fair and balanced facebook.com slash
farron balanced and of course on youtube
at youtube.com slash the ring of fire
and youtube.com slash
fairin
balanced
the tampa bay times recently had a
phenomenal article
based on emails they had obtained
thousands of pages of emails actually
that detailed the disgusting
relationship
between fox news and florida governor
ron desantis
here's what's happening according to
this wonderful report and it's a
wonderful report because they did a good
job of digging through the data not
because it tells us anything wonderful
here
but what fox news has been doing
since the
first week
after the 2020 election
is they have been
promoting ron desantis florida's
governor on their network virtually
non-stop
between that week after the election and
february of this year they had him on
their network an average of once per day
113
times
and throughout this time they were
allowing him according to the emails to
craft the narrative they were allowing
him to pick his own topics
about what he wanted to talk about on
the network
give us the talking points and we'll
just let you run with it according to
the emails
this wasn't hard-hitting journalism
hell this wasn't even news of the day
this was a major the biggest
cable news network in this country
allowing the republican governor of
florida to come on anytime he wanted
to spread his propaganda
and that is exactly what he did
they made a big spectacle
earlier this year on fox news about
desantis being down here when the
vaccines were rolling out had a 100 year
old world war ii veteran getting the
vaccine fox news did a whole big special
on it and ron desantis was heralded as
the hero
of the pandemic contrasting him by the
way
with that horrible guy up in new york
andrew cuomo who lied about the nursing
home data
and what cuomo did was terrible not just
with the nursing home data as we know
but florida was doing the same thing
yeah according to a former former data
analyst rebecca jones
who says that she was fired from her job
for not phoning up the florida data
and she has been awarded whistleblower
status
by the state of florida because they
believe there is merit to what she's
saying
but nevertheless fox news
kept bringing desantis on kept saying he
was the leader
he was showing states how it's done his
economy was booming
cases were low everybody wanted to be
ron desantis
i'm willing to bet if you ask them now
they may have a different answer
because things aren't so rosy down here
in florida anymore because of desantis's
leadership and his panderings to some of
the worst people in this state
who believe that public health issues
are really just personal policy
decisions right
you know we don't have to make a federal
case of this if i don't want to get the
vaccine and i don't want to wear a mask
that doesn't affect anybody no actually
it does
that's why it is public health
instead of personal
choice
but all along the way according to these
emails that the tampa bay times reviewed
fox news allowed desantis to come on and
spread whatever propaganda of the day he
wanted to spread
imagine if you will
let's say
the daily caller
got a hold of emails
from the rachel maddow show
or you know what here's an even better
example what if you had somebody at cnn
um i don't know let's let's name this
imaginary person chris
and let's say chris
was reaching out and helping
his
brother a politician let's say maybe
governor of new york
and they were actually coordinating on
on strategy and messaging
don't you think the right wing would be
up in arms if if something like that
were to happen
obviously i'm being facetious because
yes that did happen and yes republicans
were outraged that chris cuomo was
helping his brother embattled new york
governor not for much longer andrew
cuomo helping him craft his narrative
bringing him on his show even long
before any of that happened
to tout him as how great new york is
doing with the pandemic compared to
these other people
it's the same situation folks it's the
same situation
people are calling for cuomo to resign
from cnn or be fired from cnn and i
don't blame them
that is a massive
breach of the public's trust
but here now we have the documents that
fox news was doing the same thing with
ron desantis so where are the calls for
his resignation huh where are the calls
for the heads to roll over at fox news
it's not gonna happen because their
audience doesn't care
their audience likes it
but i tell you folks this really truly
is no different
than chris cuomo propping up his brother
andrew cuomo it's just as deceitful it's
just as disgusting
except the cuomo's are actually getting
punished for it but desantis is more
than likely to get rewarded for it
but you know who's not getting rewarded
right now
republican senator lindsey graham
last week
in the state of south carolina the
aitkin county republican party
voted to censure
republican senator lindsey graham
now so far this year when we have seen
republicans come out and censure their
own members usually it's because they've
either said they don't agree with donald
trump's big lie
or they've you know
well pretty much it's only been if they
uh aren't blindly loyal to trump so did
lindsey graham do something we don't
know about
no
it's actually much worse than that what
lindsey graham's crime is according to
this aiken county republican party in
their
censure he voted to allow the
infrastructure bill to move forward
and they censored him for it
just because he voted to allow the thing
to move forward and then of course he
praised the bipartisan infrastructure
bill the trillion dollar bill
praised it so it's a good thing
but in today's republican party
it's not only that you have to be
blindly loyal to trump but now it's you
can't even vote
on a bipartisan piece of legislation
without facing backlash from your party
because if that's the case
we're doomed
and this country is doomed
because that's what this is this is a
bipartisan infrastructure bill that
should go much further than it does but
you know we've got the three and a half
trillion bill coming up behind it
hopefully reconciliation will get that
going but either way
this is a bill that is broadly supported
across america by republicans and
democrats and independents everybody
majority of them
support this and they want this piece of
legislation because they know that
infrastructure means jobs
infrastructure means work infrastructure
means investments
in local economies
but apparently the folks over at the
aitkin county republican party didn't
get that memo
and they voted to censure him
is this a new era
have we finally
entered the era here in the united
states where neither party can vote with
the other one on a piece of legislation
where everything has to be so damn
kindergarten black and white with these
people where if it's not a republican
bill you have to vote against it even if
republicans worked on it like with the
infrastructure bill
nope republicans always have to vote
together and democrats always all have
to vote together tribalism is killing us
here in the united states
the two-party system tribalism is
killing us here in the united states
this infrastructure package is decades
overdue folks
and because lindsey graham actually said
yeah this is a good thing he gets
punished for it by these aitkin county
republicans
that's just nuts
and there's no other way to say that
this is ridiculous we cannot allow our
country to get to the point where there
is no
bipartisanship allowed where there's no
negotiations allowed
because if we ever truly hit that point
which apparently is where the aitkin
county republicans want us to go then
we're done that's it pack it up
start something new because america is
not going to continue to function
if we ever hit that point where these
aitkin county republicans clearly want
to take us
in other news mary trump
niece of former president donald trump
came out with a phenomenal article in
the new republic recently
where she basically
well she psychoanalyzed a lot
of her uncle's administration but
there's one part that i want to hit on
more than others
and that is the part where she talks
about the big lie right
the big lie that the election was stolen
which as she points out donald trump
began telling that lie on november 7th
which was the day that the 2020 election
was officially called for joe biden
and on that very day he started the big
lie
and of course he had all the horrible
people whispering in his ear that oh
yeah you got to do this giuliani was
there
mark meadows was there
all these individuals
even some private lawyers telling him
you've got to challenge us you got to
say it was fake
and mary trump says that the reason her
uncle did this
is because he was absolutely
humiliated
humiliated
by the fact
that he lost the presidential election
to joe
biden
all this was
was his hubris
not allowing him to accept the fact that
he lost to somebody like joe biden
and so he had to as a defense mechanism
for himself
create this alternative timeline this
alternative reality
where in his head
he actually won the election because of
all the fraud
so we had the election challenges we've
had the recounts
we've had to go through and recertify
we've had the signature match we now
have the ballot audits and all of it
she points out is this defense mechanism
to protect his bruised ego
the humiliation that he still feels to
this day
for losing that election
but the problem is his delusion
his defense mechanism is not just
limited to him now
it is
in psychological terms a shared
psychosis now
right it has seemingly infected millions
of others who have now been sucked into
the delusion
to believe that the 2020 election was
stolen
i mean how many polls have we seen just
over the last two months showing a
majority of republicans now think the
election
was stolen
that's a terrifying thought i haven't
seen any polls in the last couple weeks
so maybe that number's changed maybe
it's gone back down and you don't have a
majority of republicans thinking that
anymore but the fact that we ever did
that we ever even hit 60 percent of
republicans saying this is terrifying
because there was never any fraud
in fact the few cases of fraud that we
found the individual cases all appear to
be trump supporters
that's what we're living with but they
still can't accept it because he won't
accept it
and he'll never accept it
till the day he dies donald trump every
time he gets in front of a camera or he
gets a microphone is going to remind us
that he thinks the 2020 election was
stolen
he has done that this year every time he
gets on stage every time he has an
audience he says the same thing
even though the ballot audits have
produced no fraud even though the
recounts have produced no fraud even
though the lawsuits have produced no
fraud
even though the cyber symposium produced
no hacking evidence at all no fraud
he'll never stop
and marry trump's explanation of this
really lays it all bare
he won't stop because he can't stop
because his narcissism simply won't let
him
i'm farron cousins in for david pakman
we'll be right back with more of the
david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show welcome back to the
david pakman show i'm fair and cousin
sitting in for david pakman today
well
one thing that i've always been curious
about with the q conspiracy folks you
know the whole idea that the federal
government is
secretly being run by this cabal of
pedophiles and that donald trump himself
was chosen to weed them out
the thing that always
kind of bugs me about this is
why are they so silent
when actual
republicans get busted
for essentially the same thing they're
accusing the democrats of doing in the
past five days
we have now seen two
high-profile republicans
one of them just 19 years old arrested
for allegedly
trafficking minors for sex
the big one was last week 30 year old
anton lazzaro from minnesota was
arrested on charges of uh well here it
is we read this from law and crime the
indictment charges lazzaro with one
count of conspiracy to commit sex
trafficking minors five counts of sex
trafficking of minors one count of
attempted sex trafficking of a minor and
three counts of obstruction
based on the evidence obtained in this
investigation authorities believe there
may be additional victims of the alleged
conduct
now mr lazzaro
actually served as an alternate elector
in 2020 for donald trump he has given
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
republican candidates over the years
and he has been a major player in
republican politics in the state of
minnesota
and this report this arrest was so
damning that the republicans he's
donated money to over the years have
been forced to come out and say well
we're going to donate the money to
charity now
uh whatever he had given us we're going
to donate that same amount to charity
hopefully it's charities that take care
of victims of sex trafficking
but then
actually just a couple miles from where
i'm sitting right now
you had another republican from
minnesota arrested down here in florida
and that person was a
19 year old
gisella castro medina of saint paul
minnesota
she's a leader with the minnesota
college republicans which is a governing
group of young political activists
her charges include comp conspiracy to
commit sex trafficking minors sex
trafficking of a minor sex trafficking
and obstruction
now
so she was just elected or just chosen i
guess as a leader of the minnesota
college republicans so they've had to
come out and issue a statement
condemning these actions and reminding
people like hey we were all remote last
year so we don't know what's actually
happening but again the question is
where's the cue folks
you say you want to rid the government
of these sex offenders and here's to
fairly high profile republicans from
minnesota
trafficking allegedly children for sex
and people always get annoyed by the way
when you throw out the why do you say
allegedly legally we have to just so
everybody's aware of that okay they have
not been
uh char they've been charged they have
not been convicted so everything up to
that point is allegedly okay so just so
everybody's clear on that i always get a
lot of people saying why don't you just
call them that well because we don't
want to get sued okay
there's your answer but again where's
the cue people
where are you when it's one of your own
where are you on the matt gates story
because we got a lot of good information
on that last week all those text
messages the thousands
of pieces of evidence being turned over
by joel greenberg the former seminole
county tax collector down here in
florida with pictures and videos and
text messages
directly implicating matt gates in a
scheme to
buy sex from an underage girl
come on folks i mean i thought this was
what q was all about
i thought you wanted to bust the
pedophiles
as they're getting busted or at least
the people trafficking for sex are
getting busted
but nowhere to be found right
disgusting disgusting disgusting
behavior and a disgusting conspiracy
theory because yeah you know what
there's some real perverts out there if
you all put your effort into actually
helping to track these people down and
put a stop to some of these trafficking
rings
that would be worthwhile
but instead you'd rather just push these
wild conspiracies that are driving
people insane
as we saw with the california man last
week who murdered his own two kids
you know
what what a wasted opportunity if you
actually cared about sex trafficking
victims
you could have done anything to help you
could have put all of this to use for
good
but that's never what this was about
this is about attacking politicians
right
well at least these two got busted and
hopefully if what they're charged with
you know if they actually did it then
yeah hopefully they go away for a long
long time
other news other potential criminal
activity out there
last week actually in a bonus show
segment i talked about the fact that you
have all of these fake vaccine cards
that are becoming more and more
prominent specifically in north carolina
at the time
but it turns out
just a couple days ago
customs and border patrol in tennessee
confiscated
more than 3
000
fake covered vaccine
cards
in fact it was 3017
cards in 121
packages the packages were labeled paper
greeting cards used for greeting card or
paper paper card
we are starting to see and in fact
i think schumer came out and said we
need a special task force to investigate
these fake vaccine cards because yes
this is becoming a very real problem
here in this country
you know last week it was oh yeah the
college students are using it so they
don't have to get the vaccine to go back
on campus you know leaving them free to
infect others but now we find out that
the cbp of tennessee
confiscated over 3 000
of these fake vaccine cards
imagine if you will
the mentality of these people
who say well i don't want to get a shot
i don't want to run down to walgreens
real quick
i would rather waste my time going
through these dark channels on the
internet meeting with a buddy of a buddy
of a buddy behind a back alley somewhere
to buy a fake vaccine card
instead of just taking your 15 minutes
and getting your shot and being done
the
i don't even know i don't even know
anymore
but it's so demoralizing
to see that this is where our country
becomes and honestly as more and more
businesses as more and more colleges
move to these vaccine mandates
we're going to see more of this this is
not going to go away this is something
that's going to become even worse
as more places demand to see proof of
vaccination
and yes the proof of vaccination is
necessary that is the only way we're
going to stamp this thing out for good
and if we continue to let it mutate we
could all be in store for having to
develop new vaccines and getting those
as well
but these fake vaccines are putting
people at risk
and that's the real problem with it it's
not just the lying it's the fact that
your lie puts the health of other people
at
risk the vaccine card is supposed to be
a little bit of a you know security
blanket
it's supposed to be peace of mind
especially if you go into a place and
say well these people have their
vaccines i have my vaccines we should be
safe
and now we can't even trust our own
neighbors saying i got the vaccine did
you
is your card accurate is it fraudulent
this is what they're doing to us
and there's no reason for them to do
this to us
the places that have required vaccines
in order to enter them have carved out
most of them as far as i know especially
the college campuses definitely did
they've carved out exceptions for people
with religious reasons why they can't
get the vaccine or people who are
immunocompromised who medically cannot
receive the vaccine so it's not like oh
we're persecuting the people who can't
get it no we're not there's exceptions
built in for those people there's no
need for these fake vaccine cards
because every one of these cards that
goes out on the street
puts god knows how many people at risk
and there's simply no reason for that
if you want to go through all that
effort to get a vaccine card
there are much easier ways
much faster safer more effective ways to
do it
and that really is one way
just get the damn vaccine
and we started today talking about
afghanistan it's best we in that way as
well
megan mccain
megan mccain reemerged this past weekend
she's no longer on the view so she's got
to turn to twitter to get her idiotic
ideas out there to the world so she goes
on twitter
this past weekend condemns
all of these people saying we should get
out of afghanistan including the
biden administration saying this here's
her tweet
democrats like to wax poetic a lot about
what my dad would have done and said
most of the time reinventing some weird
fantasy of who he was
let me tell you one damn thing
he would be raging in public and a
president biden about his this af
withdrawal in afghanistan raging
you know megan you don't really need to
tell us that
for two reasons first of all nobody
asked
i'm just going to throw that out there
first literally nobody asked
and you know why because that's my
second reason you don't need to tell us
this because
nobody cares
i'm sorry i don't care if you think that
john mccain was a hero if you think he
was a saint or if you think he was just
a
another conservative war hawk which he
was
i don't care
what the man would have thought
about the withdrawal of troops from
afghanistan do you know why i don't care
because he's he's not a u.s senator
anymore he's
he's not even alive
so whether he supported it
or was against it please somebody
explain to me how that is relevant to
anything on this planet
honestly it's kind of the same argument
that republicans oh well what would the
founding father thing who cares
who cares is the answer to that question
who cares what the founders would have
thought
oh the same people that thought a black
slave only counted as three-fifths of a
human being yeah i don't care what their
opinion would be of today's current
political climate
oh john mccain is not happy
that we're pulling troops out of
afghanistan yeah thanks for reminding us
that the man never met an international
conflict that he didn't immediately fall
in love with
that's what megan mccain was really
doing there and this is why folks it
really is so dangerous
when democrats prop up these individuals
you know we've seen it with liz cheney
we saw it with john mccain just because
they hate the same person we didn't like
donald trump
that doesn't mean they're our friends
that doesn't even mean there are allies
john mccain when he was still in the
senate still voted with republicans was
it 90 percent of the time liz cheney's
over 90 percent of the time
these people are not our friends they
are not our allies just because we
dislike the same person the enemy of my
enemy is not always my friend and we
have to get that through our heads and
thank you megan mccain for taking the
time over the weekend to remind us
that at the end of the day
your father god rest his soul
was just another republican
who wanted the u.s to be involved in as
many international conflicts as humanly
possible
i want to thank david and the entire
staff at the david pakman show for being
so welcoming to me here i will be with
you once again tomorrow and until then
if for some reason you want any more of
me you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com
farronbalancedyoutube.com the ring of
fire twitter facebook and instagram at
farren balanced stay tuned for today's
bonus show for the members we've got
some really great stories coming up i'm
fair and cousins in for david pakman
thanks for watching
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman